YURI GRINSHTEYN:
During our last visit
we used Stackdriver Trace
to diagnose a latency issue
in our application.
Today, we'll use Profiler
to dig into a service
and see what could be
making it run slowly.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[THEME MUSIC]
The last time you were
here, we found an issue
where a bug was
causing high latency.
Today, we'll dig into
a particular service
with Profiler.
Whereas Trace tells us how
long service calls take,
Profiler is going
to show us what's
happening within each service.
Let's start digging in.
We have a few services
that are being profiled.
Let's pick the frontend
service since any issues there
will directly impact
user experience.
Let's use the CPU Time
metric to understand
how our service
might be bottlenecked
by CPU utilization.
Profiler takes random sample
profiles of the system
and combines the data to
show you what functions
are using the most resources.
The graph shows
the function calls
grouped by their use of the
resource-- in this case, CPU,
where the x-axis is
the amount of CPU
and the y-axis shows
parent-child relationships.
In this case, the
majority of the CPU
is used by the ServeHTTP call.
The expanded view shows
almost half of this
is caused by viewCartHandler,
which in turn is mostly
caused by getRecommendations.
Now we know exactly
where the time is going.
If this is the result of a
recently deployed change,
we can roll it back
and let the engineering
team know exactly
where the problem is
so they can easily fix it.
Sure glad we got
that taken care of.
Now, you may be thinking,
sure, that looks easy.
But how much work will
it be to get Profiler
to work with my applications?
Well, it turns out that
it's not much work at all.
Let's take a look.
No matter which language
your service is written in,
it's easy to instrument
your code with Profiler.
Simply install the
Profiler package
for the language your
service is written in,
import it in your code, and
then call the start method.
Even better, you can specify
the version of your service
you're profiling
so that later, you
can compare profiles created
from different versions
and understand how code pushes
are impacting infrastructure
utilization and performance.
Now, one thing you
should be aware of
is that adding Profiler to
Java code is a bit different.
You need to pass the path to
the library as an argument
when you start your JVM.
Once your code is
instrumented with Profiler,
profiles will be shipped
to the Stackdriver backend.
From there, you
can start analyzing
how your code is using
system resources right away
and fixing problems like
the one we dealt with today.
Now that you've learned
how to use Profiler,
you'll be much better
prepared to optimize
your service for resource
utilization and performance.
That's it for this episode.
Come back soon for more on
how Stackdriver can help you
keep your application healthy.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[THEME MUSIC]